jade la guerre civile la plupart des
français évacués mais à messieurs
bonsoir avant de développer en images et
avec des invités et une belle on vous
l'a dit si l'actualité de la journée
juste le temps d'un regard sur le temps
qu'il va faire depuis le début de la
semaine en effet une partie de la france
est en vacances demain soir au plus tard
samedi à midi une autre partie le sera
mais pour tout le monde même régime
celui de la douche écossaise avec plus
de froid coach haut et plus douce que 2
sec alors laurent broomhead pour demain
après demain dimanche
l'écouté il va continuer à faire
extrêmement doué douceur est synonyme de
nuages une 'grande dépression' zone de
mauvais temps sur les îles britanniques
nous envoie des vagues depuis la
dernière en date va achever de traverser
le pays dans l'est demain on la retrouve
le matin des vosges jura au nord des
alpes et jusqu'au midi toulousain et
pyrénées centrales des pluies qui se
déplaceront dans la journée vers le
sud-est pour arroser les régions
méditerranéennes et la corse où elles
prendront un caractère orageux après
leur passage temps variable comme on dit
c'est à dire beaucoup de nuages des
averses aussi quelques éclaircies rares
et courtes sur le nord un peu plus
longues sur la moitié sud
ça c'est pour vendredi samedi maintenant
ça se gâte sur la région delà des
pyrénées et des côtes méditerranéennes
où il y aura beaucoup de nuages et des
pluies sur le reste du pays un temps
variable des éclaircies un peu plus
longues malgré un passage de pluies dans
la journée qui partira des côtes de la
manche le matin pour atteindre le soir
le massif central et le nord des alpes
et le nord-est ça c'est samedi
et puis dimanche enfin on va s'en c'est
un petit peu et je pense qu'il fera plus
ensoleillé plus frais également avec des
averses de neige dans le nord-est du
pays ailleurs donc des éclaircies plus
belles forêts puisque je parle de neige
les conseils les cartes dans une
enneigement pardon aujourd'hui très mou
des valeurs moyennes vers 15 cents
mètres d'altitude région par région en
fait la couverture neigeuse est assez
bonne malheureusement aujourd'hui et
demain il va plus il a plu il pleuvra
jusqu'à 2500 mètres d'altitude
mais je voulais dit ça s'améliorera pour
lescure tout au moins dimanche avec le
retour des températures plus froides sas
et vaud jura haute-savoie et savoie est
aussi le massif central et les pyrénées
dont vous voyez de l'année
f donc cette neige et tentera un peu de
fond' mais je pense que ça s'améliorera
et donc qu'on peut rester confiant pour
l'esc heures voici les dernières pour
les alpes
on peut faire confiance pour les
prévisions parce que la semaine derrière
c'était pas terrible la semaine dernière
on a eu droit
on a le droit à un miracle la semaine
dernière ge espère un miracle pour
dimanche bien notre dossier du jour
maintenant qui est aussi le vôtre
l'inflation encore un indice deux
chiffres pour le mois de février je vous
le disais hier 1 1%
c'était un gag 9% en janvier et la
sphère devient préoccupante
nos voisins nous allons nous voir ne
sont guère mieux lotis mais ce n'est pas
une consolation en tout cas il faut une
explication à cette surchauffe général
et mondial c'est ce que nous allons
faire avec notre service économique
mais tout d'abord le constat le constat
à travers un exemple celui du logement
malgré les désaccords sur l'importance
des hausses de prix du logement une
chose est certaine
acheter un logement aujourd'hui revient
beaucoup plus cher qu'à la même époque
l'année dernière
et à cela trois raisons majeures le prix
du terrain à bâtir a augmenté l'an passé
de 20 % à 25 % celui des matériaux de
construction s'est accru de plus de 13 %
les salaires dans l'industrie du
bâtiment ont progressé entre décembre 78
et décembre 79 de 12% l'an passé affirme
différents professionnels le prix d'un
logement neuf en france a augmenté en
moyenne de 20 % contre 10 %
il y a deux ans cette augmentation est
beaucoup plus rapide que celle du coût
de la vie et que celle des salaires il
faut dire que l'offre moins abondante et
le gonflement de la demande ont favorisé
une hausse des prix que certains
constructeurs n'ont pas toujours bien
voulu ou bien su maîtriser enfin la
flambée des taux d'intérêt aux états
unis a déclenché dans le monde entier un
renchérissement du coût des critiques
résultat il faut emprunter plus pour le
même nombre de mètres carrés ou bien se
contenter d'un appartement plus petit on
estime actuellement contre la hausse des
prix du logement et celle du crédit
il faut des revenus supérieure de 20 à
30% à ceux de l'an passé pour acquérir
un logement identique dans la région
parisienne c'est un phénomène qu'on
constate un peu partout en europe une
inconnue la hausse des taux d'intérêt ne
va-t-elle pas ralentir le rythme des
achats de logements alors c'est pour
lutter précisément contre l'inflation et
une trop grosse demande de crédit que
les américains ont choisi le comme
politique l'augmentation des taux
d'intérêt il faut dire que là bas la
hausse des prix atteint 1,4 pour cent en
février et que la récession menace le
dernier plan carter suicide pour
l'instant le scepticisme et ses
premières conséquences
on était d'entraîner une remontée
spectaculaire du dollar et une chute de
l'or jaksic le dollar remonte et l'or
est à la baisse le processus se déroule
sans grand mouvement de panique mais
avec des incertitudes que les
spécialistes eux mêmes ont du mal à
analyser le redressement du dollar sur
le marché des changes est naturellement
liée à la politique américaine du crédit
un certain tassement des cours des
matières premières et relèvement depuis
une semaine du taux d'intérêt de
plusieurs banques américaines
les américains qui veulent emprunter
devront donc payer le loyer du dollar
plus cher on souhaiterait même qu'ils
soient découragés de le faire mais ce
relèvement des taux d'intérêt pourrait
dans un premier temps accroître
l'inflation puisque les crédits seraient
moins facilement disponibles et faute de
crédits l'activité économique serait
ralentie et en fin de compte on pourrait
entrer dans une période de récession
c'est ce que redoute tous les américains
qui naît on lit chez l'enfant
le montant du taux d'intérêt a augmenté
de 50% en moins de six mois
je suis docteur
le travail est très petit et tu rêves
prix fort la bent el hammam faut manger
et 13 ans et le plante l'appelation de
jimmy carter s'il pénalise des
américains attirent les détenteurs des
capitaux flottants qui ont tout intérêt
aujourd'hui à déplacer leurs emprunts
effectués sur des métaux précieux comme
l'or pour les reporter sur le dollar
puisque les taux d'intérêt de cette
monnaie de vienne d'un excellent rapport
conséquence de cette flambée américaine
une confiance renouvelée et renaissante
dans le dollar qui conduit les pays
pétroliers par exemple à reconstituer
leurs réserves en dollars et pour les
autres pour l'europe par exemple la
tentation de suivre le mouvement et de
transformer ces francs en dollars pour
profiter naturellement des taux
d'intérêt exorbitants qui existent
aujourd'hui aux états unis
voyez cette menace de récession aux
états unis et cette flambée de
l'inflation non seulement en occident
mais aussi dans tous les pays
socialistes rang des boursiers nerveux
après wall street hier soir c'est la
bourse de paris qui a ce matin accusé le
coup et les allemands eux mêmes si
solide jusque là s'inquiète la loi sur
les prix que l'on appelle capitaliste et
à l'est les pics l'on nomme socialistes
ont en commun la même maladie la fièvre
de l'appelation à l'est pour mesurer
cette fièvre et bien que sont peut-être
les files dans les grands magasins
à l'ouest le thermomètre eh bien c'est
la boue c'est la plus grande course du
monde
wall street à new york a pris peur
depuis quelques temps devant une hausse
des prix qui dépasse 18 % en rythme
annuel aux etats-unis wall street prend
peur également devant la flambée des
taux d'intérêts jamais au cours de leur
histoire les etats unis ont connu un
crédit aussi élevé la baisse aujourd'hui
à la bourse de paris traduit bien cette
inquiétude une attitude qui est partagé
à londres à rome mais aussi à bonn en
effet en allemagne au mois de février
eh bien les allemands n'ont pas mieux
fait que les français en matière
d'appelation pas de doute c'est bien à
cause de l'essence et du pétrole plus
cher que les allemands depuis six ans
champion du monde de la stabilité avec
des prix qui n'augmentait que de 3% par
an
renouer avec un taux d'inflation qui est
maintenant de 5,7 pour cent en cours
d'année ce taux risquent d'ailleurs de
dépasser les 6 et demi pour cent c'est
ce qu'indiquent les prévisions les plus
réalistes tout ce qui est fabriqué
directement ou indirectement à partir de
sous produits pétroliers coûte donc plus
cher c'est notamment le cas des voitures
et autres objets mécaniques dans la
construction desquels il entre une part
de matières plastiques ou synthétiques
jusqu'à présent ce taux d'inflation
n'est pas entré si l'on peut dire dans
la chair ou dans le soulier d'une
prospérité allemand de plus fragile
qu'on le croit même si dans les banques
le crédit est maintenant devenu plus
cher c'est vrai aussi que comparé à
celui d'autres pays européens
le taux d'inflation allemand peut
sembler bien faible il reste que cette
inflation a déjà égratigné le niveau de
vie de nos voisins les allemands le
ressentent surtout lorsqu il calcule ce
que leur coûteront leurs prochaines
vacances
les prix des transports ferroviaires
aériens des croisières et des voyages
organisés ont grimpé en flèche
on sent dès à présent qu'il va falloir
se limiter cet été une consolation les
prix alimentaires sont restées
relativement bas c'est là un facteur de
stabilité très important car cela évite
à l'inflation allemande de déraper vers
des zones dangereuses
il faut en effet se souvenir que l'on
vit encore ici dans la hantise de
l'inflation de la fin des années 20 et
qu'en allemagne un taux d'inflation à
l'italienne ou même supérieure à 10%
deviendrait très vite un facteur
d'insécurité politique tout à fait
insupportable
elle n'aura pu en parler à madame
thatcher dont il est l auto checkers
aujourd'hui madame thatcher qui elle
même vient de lancer toujours
aujourd'hui un budget anti
inflationniste qui comporte une chute
importante des dépenses publiques
les experts s'inquiètent dans ces
conditions d'un possible accroissement
du chômage
il est possible que l'on parle l'on en
parle lors du prochain conseil européen
qui se déroulera à luxembourg sans doute
le 27 et le 28 avril
c'est ce que je viens d'apprendre à
l'instant
source officieuse pour ce qui est
maintenant du relèvement du taux
d'intérêt des caisses d'epargne dont je
vous parlais hier ce commentaire du
socialiste laurent fabius
l' épargne populaire continuera à être
spoliés voilà qui nous amène à la
politique avec tout d'abord les journées
parlementaires du rpr qui se poursuivent
à saint-raphaël journée marquée par un
incident que nous rapporte maintenant
daniel brain de saint-raphaël parti tout
seul ce matin de son hôtel michel debré
s'est retrouvé une fois de plus seul à
son banc dont l'église de forme les
mimosas
on y célébrait une messe en la mémoire
de georges pompidou sur un banc voisin
jacques chirac et claude labit la petite
phrase meurtrière jacques chirac est
notre meilleur candidat
depuis la veille bourdonne à ses
oreilles à la sortie de l'église face à
claude labbé il explose
je suis tombé dans un guet-apens si on a
voulu me dicter ma conduite et bien on
n'a pas choisi la bonne méthode
je ne participerai plus à votre avis
jacques chirac conciliant lance les
absents ont toujours tort réplique de
debray apparemment les présents au style
deuxième épisode le déjeuner aux salins
à hier devrait toujours passer cette
fois face aux journalistes il répète à
leur demande et et à de multiples
reprises les mêmes propos dans une salle
voisine du même restaurant
jacques chirac pressé de questions a
fait je ne suis pour rien dans ce
différend
les paroles de claude labbé n'était pas
téléguidé une fois de plus c'est la
presse qui a grossi cette affaire quant
à la baie et bien lui il persiste et
signe j'ai parlé spontanément
j'appartiens à la même génération de
gaulliste que michel debré maintenant il
faut laisser la place aux plus jeunes
michel debré devrait quitter la côte
d'azur 2 mamata décidera t-il d'être
candidat sans le soutien du rpr c'est
évidemment la question qui est posée
présidentielle toujours que le monde y
pense un nouveau candidat écologique
jean claude delarue 40 ans qui c'est la
politique qui a récemment rompu avec
brice lalonde et pas de l'impossible
d'ailleurs qu'il y ait d'autres
candidats écologique en quatre
20 1 jean claude delarue et président de
sos environnement vous pourrez
l'entendre dans notre dernier journal et
à en croire ce sondage du périodique le
sauvage qui reparaît sondage de la
sofres 27% des français envisageraient
de voter écologie l'année prochaine
autre sondage celui de paris match au 2e
tour giscaro car 50 50
giscard mitterrand 56 44 giscard marché
70 30 da sauvage public paris match
c'est peut-être ce qui a incité le
socialiste pierre bérégovoy écrire
aujourd'hui dans l'unité nous devons
choisir le meilleur des nôtres et pas
celui que les autres préfèrent ça c'est
une petite pierre dans le jardin de
michel rocard
et puis un grand meeting du parti
communiste ce soir porte de pantin thème
central de la réunion les droits de
l'homme ce sera aussi l'occasion d'une
manifestation de solidarité à georges
marchais qui doit s'exprimer vers 20h30
porte de pantin donc par ailleurs le pc
a répété qu'il était favorable à
l'implantation d'une centrale nucléaire
à bata nous disons pas non à plogoff
d'une pcsi s'il convient mais les études
doivent être débattues avec la
population voté la fin de la grève des
journalistes du matin le quotidien
reparaîtra les journalistes qui
s'expliqueront dans leur journal demain
entendaient protester contre la décision
de leur direction d'embaucher le
billettiste andrée cros tard un mariage
a été célébré aujourd'hui un mariage un
petit peu particulier puisqu'il réunit
l'informatique et le droit l'union des
industries métallurgiques et
métallurgiques pardon vient en effet de
mettre dans un ordinateur tout le droit
social et les conventions collectives
qui le concerne c'est la première fois
qu'une telle expérience est réaliste et
jacques martineau voilà la documentation
classique du service du personnel une
grande entreprise
des centaines de casseurs des dizaines
texte de convention collective ou
d'arrêt faisant jurisprudence pour
résoudre un problème qui sort un peu de
l'ordinaire il faut fouiller là dedans
et bien sûr cela prend beaucoup de temps
trop de temps et du temps perdu mettre
tout cela dans un ordinateur était
évidemment
en temps c'est maintenant chose faite il
aura fallu pour cela un an de travail à
9 juristes pour découper et classé 90
mille documents l'ensemble de tous le
droit social
le résultat est frappant peut-on par
exemple connaître la réglementation des
congés en fonction de l'ancienneté
il suffit simplement de faire entrer les
mots congés payés et suppléments
ancienneté en quelques secondes
l'ordinateur sans les textes qui s'y
rapportent
ici par exemple la convention collective
de la métallurgie du tout nous indique
que dans ce département 15 ans
d'ancienneté donne droit à un jour de
congé supplémentaire cela c'est
évidemment tout à fait classique mais
l'ordinateur ne restera pas démunis
si on lui pose de questions ou plus
inattendus prenons un exemple un peu
plus farfelues imaginons je sois patron
que je demande à ma secrétaire d'emmener
mon chien se promener se fait renverser
par une voiture est ce que c'est un
excellent travail correspondant à votre
question
un travail de recherche sur la
jurisprudence
et on apprend ainsi qu un cas semblable
s'est déjà produit il employé d'une
pâtisserie qui promenait le chien de son
patron était tombé parce que ce chien
s'était battu avec un autre chien mais
c'était hors des heures de travail le
tribunal a considéré que ce n'était donc
pas un accident du travail
cette innovation simple dans la
conception va donc changer la vie de
bien des juristes lesquels on ne sait
pas encore l'union des industries
métallurgiques qu'il sera en effet plus
tard les conditions d'accès à cet
ordinateur
l'étranger maintenant le shah d'iran
dans un état critique que l'ablation de
sarah est devenue impérative elle a
atteint 10 fois son volume normal
l'ex souverain qui se trouve depuis
trois jours dans un hôpital du caire et
dans un état de grande faiblesse
générale il devrait être opéré après
nous tunisie 15 membres du commando qui
avait attaqué gafsa dans le sud du pays
ont été condamnées à mort
on les accuse d'avoir tenté un coup
d'état avec l'aide de la libye tchad les
combats ont repris à n'djamena les
partisans du président et ceux du
ministre de la défense se bat maintenant
depuis six jours et la guerre civile et
général serge me serais analyse les
raisons de ces affrontements et détaille
les forces en présence peuplé de 4
millions d'habitants
le tchad est un pays pauvre qui ne cesse
de s'appauvrir
il est composé de deux régions
totalement dissemblables qui pose d'une
façon permanente le problème de l'unité
de ce pays
le nord et peuplé par les toubous
éleveurs nomades musulmans le nord est
désertique le sud un peu plus riches est
essentiellement peuplé d'agriculteurs de
religion chrétienne ou animiste des
noirs sur le terrain à n'djamena parmi
les forces qui s'affrontent depuis
plusieurs jours apparaît encore plus
clairement cette division du pays ainsi
le nordiste goukouni qui dispose
d'environ six mille huit cents hommes et
musulmans arabes et tous bouts il occupe
le nord de la capitale
il sonne habré est lui aussi musulman
elle dispose d'environ 5000 hommes qui
occupent la partie est ouest de la ville
le sud de n'djamena est occupée par
wadal kamougué à la tête de six mille
hommes des noirs chrétiens ou animistes
les parties en présence disposent
d'armes lourdes de diverses origines
il ya beaucoup d'armes soviétique qui
viennent de libye hier dans cette
situation les quelques 1200 soldats
français observe une totale neutralité
ses troupes sont stationnés dans les
locaux de la gendarmerie djamena où sont
réfugiés sans européens cinq ans
d'autres restent encore en vie
dans cette guerre de rivalités tribales
outre la protection des civils les
troupes françaises jour est plutôt un
rôle de médiateur elle reste en place
pour préserver l'intégrité territoriale
d'un pays dont la position stratégique
est importante en afrique orientale
le comité olympique américain pourrait
répondre favorablement à l'invitation de
moscou son président l'a fait savoir
aujourd'hui au retour d'un voyage en
urss
les athlètes japonais ont fait de même
les anglais l'avaient fait la semaine
dernière
alors pour parler maintenant du point de
départ de cette affaire et a dû boycott
décrété par jimmy carter
voici maintenant des informations plus
précises sur l'afghanistan
hier je vous parlais du témoignage d'un
membre de la ligue des droits de l'homme
et bien ce témoin le voici maintenant
interrogé par gérard ce bac il y à
utilisation d'armes chimiques
par exemple dans la vallée du cunard les
l'armée soviétique a utilisé semble-t-il
3 sorte d'incapacité non mortels mais
extrêmement grave et qui ont pu
provoquer la mort par asphyxie à savoir
le lacrymogènes mais très concentré
provoquant les maux de tête et qui a
provoqué 13 morts par asphyxie dans un
des villages du kunar
le 29 février 1980 ensuite un irritant
de pau projetée par les hélicoptères
sous l'aspect de vapeur d'eau bouillante
et qui faisait le soulever sur la peau
des pustules et causer des démangeaisons
tels que par exemple le résistant été
obligé de lâcher son arme pour ce
grappes et l'oeuf le troisième c'était
un hilarant causant un fou rire et
entraînant l'évanouissement
mais ces armes ont précédé ou accompagné
l'utilisent à l'utilisation par dont une
à pales et c'est le napal qui a
profondément traumatisé les populations
civiles et les résistants afghans le
napalm qu'ils décrivent comme étant la
bombe jet feu il n'emploie pas le mot
napalm ils ne le connaissent pas pour u
c'est quelque chose de nouveau et c'est
pourquoi je crois qu'ils n'inventent pas
il parle d'une essence qui tombe du ciel
et qui brûlent leurs chants qui brûle
troupeau et qui brûlent leurs femmes et
leurs enfants et c'est ça qu'ils
craignent et contre laquelle ils se
sentent sans défense du tout on a parlé
également d'un certain nombre de
massacres de villages entiers est ce que
vous en avez eu confirmation
j'ai eu de très nombreuses confirmations
du massacre du village
le kerala il faut savoir que kerala se
situe en effet à l'entrée de la vallée
du canard et que c'est un massacre qu'il
y a eu lieu au printemps dernier il ya
presque un an maintenant part pour
assurer aux soviétiques une base sûre à
l'entrée mène de la vallée du kunar
semble-t-il c'est l'explication où toute
la population masculine des adolescents
et des petits garçons jusqu aux
vieillards ont été fusillés en effet
d'après vos témoignages les témoignages
que vous avez recueilli vous accusez
donc pratiquement les soviétiques
aujourd'hui de génocide
je ne veux pas employer de termes de
valeur mais je dois constater d'une part
que le peuple afghan est persuadé de
l'intention émise par ce commandant
sadique de la prison de pour l'etg a
pris à savoir nous ne laisserons aucun
millions d'afghans vivant d'autre part
l'offre qu'à distance centrale
entièrement bouclé par l'armée
soviétique est menacée de famine
parce que les cultures ont été détruites
vous êtes sûr de la véracité des
témoignages vous avez recueillis je suis
sûr de l'état d'esprit qui est celui
d'une population traumatisée
je suis sûr que quelque chose de très
grave a poussé 600000 personnes parmi
les gens les plus pauvres du monde à
fuir et abandonner tout ce qu'ils
possédaient est un témoignage d'autant
plus intéressant que monsieur barry par
le plusieurs dialectes
alors voilà droits de l'homme toujours
avec nous sur ce plateau je pense que
vous l'avez reconnu john baez la
chanteuse jeane baisse qui est passionné
pour la cause des réfugiés vietnamiens
et cambodgiens
il revient de là bas une baisse qui a
fondé l'année dernière une organisation
humanitaire qui est destiné à prévenir
et à guérir toutes les atteintes aux
droits de l'homme cette organisation
s'appelle humanitas john baez déjà
beaucoup de monde s'occupait
de droits de l'homme pourquoi vous y
avez déjà amnesty international il ya
toujours la possibilité de faire encore
autre chose humanitas pour a déjà aidé
faire des choses que amnesty
international ne peut pas faire par
exemple travaillé pour les réfugiés
c'est ce que vous êtes en veille abus et
les excès des uns et des autres c'est à
dire de droite comme de gauche pour
l'instant vous occuper beaucoup des pays
socialistes le cambodge le vietnam est
est ce que vous pourriez vous occupé par
exemple d'afghanistan ce que nous on
entend avec monsieur bart et je crois
que la seule façon dont on peut parler
des droits de l'homme équitablement ses
deux condamné les abus
partout où il se situe et à chaque fois
je crois que c'est difficile évidemment
pour ceux qui ont des idéologies qui ont
un préféré mais un groupe comme un
initié international ou un groupe comme
le nôtre humanitas et bien c'est être
aveugle à ces différences et de parler
pour les afghans pour les argentins pour
les chiliens pour les vietnamiens pour
les camps miotti aujourd'hui on tourne
une manifestation l'ambassade
d'argentine organisé par le club
socialiste des droits de l'homme c'est
un dossier l'amérique latine qui vous
intéressera un jour pour lequel vous
combattrez
lorsque j'ai surtout comment occuper
c'était au chili pendant beaucoup
d'années je luttais contre ce que
faisait l'amérique au vietnam je leur
ferais si c'était nécessaire et vers la
fin de cette époque j'ai commencé à
m'occuper déviation t3 clamé c'est en
fait un des roches y connaissez bien
c'est à dire essentiellement du vietnam
et du cambodge
il y a dix ans vous étiez considéré
comme la pasionaria de la cause
vietnamienne dans les universités
américaines vous défendiez la cause de
ceux qui luttaient pour leur liberté
est ce que vous imaginiez le type de
régime qu'ils étaient en train de fonder
que vous étiez en train de soutenir
eh bien je crois que c'est entre nous
qui voit ce qui se passe lorsqu'un pays
ne connaît que la violence année après
année et bien ce serait étonnant si tout
d'un coup il devient méchant le plus
paisible du monde au vietnam par exemple
j'ai été étonné de
toute l'ampleur de ces relations nous
avons l'intention de continuer à les
dénoncer il ya deux cent cinquante mille
personnes dont des cadres et du question
dans des prisons et au fond j'ai été
trahi pour le travail que l'arrêté que
j'avais fait nous voulions que ce pays l
autodétermination nous pensons la même
chose sur le laos le cambodge et se sont
devenus des sautes situation totalitaire
si le mois dernier au début du mois
dernier début février à la frontière
entre le cambodge et la thaïlande alors
je vous propose de faire une petite
pause dans cette interview et d'écouter
ce que fut votre combat ce moment là car
vous aviez combattu en chantant en
chantant pour des petits cambodgiens
réfugiés dans le camp de karine dingue
et je crois que c'est assez touchant
nous écouter a love my dog
durée 2 à la mayenne mayenne mis à l'eau
mayemba nakata où tu es mal et lorraine
à la mad dog and mad dog love me alone
magnum à 2,48 mal au dos alors ce
reportage tourné par jirari n'est écrit
ses roues est effectivement très
touchants mais vos détracteurs vous ont
dit à ce moment-là que c'était du cinéma
que ça servait à rien que la frontière
du cambodge vous a été interdite thibout
n'avait rien pu faire ce que nous avons
essayé de faire c'était d'aller près de
cette frontière
bon tant pis si on appelle ça du cinéma
je fais ce que j'ai à faire et je
cherchais à montrer au monde que le
gouvernement fasse qu'on appelle le
gouvernement de phnom penh ne permettent
pas aux médecins de rentrer au cambodge
nous avions des médecins de médecins
français sans frontières attac chants du
monde entier qui disait nous voilà nous
les médecins nous venons avec des
intentions pacifiques sans esprit
politique 106 théologie s'il n'y a pas
de médecin mois prochain au cambodge ce
ne sont pas des moutons et suspicions et
des faits soit plus rapide
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas dans toute
cette affaire le bras disons 'peut-être
le coeur en tout cas la bonne conscience
de jimmy carter
l'étoile brille j'espère j'espère que je
suis une bonne conscience pour moi et
pour les gens qui m'écoutent c'est tout
merci pour votre témoignage
norbert prince terre un ancien chef
d'equipe d'une entreprise de peinture
navale est resté trois heures sur une
civière dans les couloirs du tribunal de
marseille atteint d'une maladie grave la
saturn et à la suite d'utilisation dans
son travail d'une peinture à base de
plomb il avait porté plainte il ya deux
ans et demi contre son employeur qui ne
respectaient pas certaine réglementation
sur l'utilisation de ce type de peinture
marée noire le directeur de la comex
société spécialisée dans les travaux
sous-marins estime qu'il est tout à fait
possible de pomper les dix mille tonnes
de fuel qui reste dans la partie avant
du tanio ou même de le renflouer de
renflouer les parts actuellement immergé
par 87 mètres de fond en attendant les
spécialistes estiment qu'une tonne et
demie de fioul ses chats tous les jours
de cette étape et puis ces images
étonnantes qui vont faire frémir plus
d'un et plus d'une d'entre vous mais
rassurez vous ils ont été tournées en
australie des millions de souris ont
envahi l'état de victoria et dévasté les
cultures ces petits mammifères
affectionne tout particulièrement le blé
stockés dans des silos mais il ne
dédaigne pas à l'occasion s'attaquer aux
pneus des voitures les autoroutes et les
plages ont envahi finalement
personne ne sait comment les faire fuir
john bell a fermé les yeux tennis
deuxième journée de l'open de nice une
déception yannick noah face à francesco
luna
quant à bord deux petits sets qui ont
suffi pour s'imposer aux dépens de
phrénologiques de matches que nous
commente maintenant alain soler borg est
de retour avec son coup droit vengeurs
borg est de retour avec son revers
assassin bref bord n'a pas changé
semble-t-il
il est partout sur le court au point
parfois donné l'impression de jouer seul
aujourd'hui par exemple ce n'est pas
franulovic battue 6 2 6 2 qui nous
démentira
petite journée en revanche pour yannick
noah grippé fiévreux noah a donc joué
comme un malade en dépit de
l'interdiction de son médecin
pas de position de résistance donc aux
assauts de francisco luna le troisième
joueur espagnol
noah et des faits ici à nice 6 3 6 3
freeks pour sa part s'incline en trois
sets face à manuel orantes s seule
satisfaction du jour pour les français
la victoire de gilles moreton face à
l'israélien each day et bien car c'est
aujourd'hui à auteuil c'est une
combinaison gagnante 11 4 3 qui vous
rapporte vous le voyez dans l'ordre un
peu plus de 1000 francs 1029 francs et
d'un ordre différent
cent soixante quatre ans pas beaucoup
pour 5 francs il ya bresse vous a
conseillé cette combinaison en cinq
chevaux dans un ordre différent
ce soir c'est hervé claude qui vous
présente les dernières nouvelles aux
alentours de 23h30 et puis demain
antennes 2010 sera réalisée en direct
depuis le dernier vol d'une caravelle
qui part pour le musée de l'air au
bourget c'est une grande première
au cours de cette édition le présentée
par patrick lecocq l'avion effectuera un
survol complet de paris à 300 mètres
d'altitude c'était à peu près au niveau
de la toile puis je vous rappelle qu'au
début de ce journal laurent broomhead a
prévu un temps médiocre et pluvieux pour
demain voilà ce journal est maintenant
terminée bonsoir à tous
admirateur